hi I'm Eric Voss and in the wake of
Avengers infinity war many of us have
still been wondering what the hell is
going on with Hulk in this movie
why was he jogging with everyone in the
trailer but in the actual movie he got
performance anxiety after that initial
beatdown by Thanos Bruce kept asking him
if he could come out to play but then
Hulk just kept responding no there are a
few interesting explanations for why the
Hulk was being a little shy boy in
Infinity Ward one that involves Loki
he's not actually been dead Wow but
let's start with the simplest answer
Hulk's pride was stunned The Hulk at the
beginning of this movie had just come
off a long undefeated winning streak on
Sekar in thor ragnarok that movie
featured hulk has less of an
uncontrollable rage monster and more of
as a cocky smack-talking pro-athlete
sure the Hulk has been beaten down
before in the at Norton Hulk movie and
an age of Ultron of course but those
defeats probably seem like distant
memories to the showboating prizefighter
that we saw in Ragnarok and like many
Big Time boxers a really nasty KO can be
devastating to their confidence
paralyzing them from ever wanting to
enter the ring again or sometimes
literally paralyzing them so that could
be part of what we're seeing with hole
after Thanos while I'm sim in the
opening sequence it's not that he's
scared it's that he's a fighter who
forgot how to lose but that's just one
way to look at it if you see infinity
war is a continuation of Hulk from
Ragnarok other people are more focused
on hoax attitude the last time he was on
earth at the end of Avengers age of
Ultron bringing us to the second
explanation Hulk
hates earth age of Ultron ended with
Hulk in the Quinjet ignoring black
widows please to come back by that point
Hulk was pissed that the people of Earth
would never love him as a hero despite
them saving their asses repeatedly the
people of Earth had feared him
ostracized him tried to restrain him his
decision leave wasn't just a measure to
protect humans from his own destructive
tendencies it was also to escape to some
where people didn't scorn him
that led him to Sekar in Ragnarok where
people loved him so much they Rushmore
him into the sides of their buildings
and may be returning to earth has
brought back the feeling of being a
despised outcast that hope just doesn't
want to deal with again really some
combination of these two explanations
hoax ego from Ragnarok and Hulk not
getting enough respect on earth is
essentially what the directors of
infinity war have suggested Joe Russo
said on a podcast that Hulk and banner
are constantly in conflict over control
and that Hulk is annoyed banner only
once and for fighting and Hocus had
enough of saving banners ass really when
you think about it it's more interesting
to see banner go through this conflict
because it flips the classic Bruce
Banner struggle of not wanting the Hulk
to take over by struggling to invoke the
Hulk we get to see Mark Ruffalo react to
the surprise and embarrassment and
frustration of having to fight as a
human and it leaves the reunion of the
two halves as a potential payoff in the
next Avengers movie but but there are a
few nagging details about banners
storyline infinity war that some fans
are still looking for answers to for
example when banner crash lands in the
sanctum sanctorum how does he know about
all the details about Thanos and the
Infinity stones to report them to Tony
Stark in the past banner wasn't able to
remember anything from the time while
Hulk was at the wheel like in Ragnarok
when Hulk reverted back to banner banner
was totally bewildered it's the city
sokovia every save it listen why did she
go V Ultron that was two years ago are
you saying
banner experiences a complete blackout
when Hulk takes over and he seemed to be
in Hulk mode from the end of Ragnarok
through the first part of infinity war
right up until he lands in the sanctum
and any chatter by Thanos or ebony maw
about the Infinity stones or at thanasis
relationship to Loki would have been
heard by Hulk not banner now one theory
out there that has been gaining some
momentum is that this might not actually
be banner banner is actually lucky in
disguise I know I know how I'm good loki
still be alive well everyone is still
alive in new rockstars theory time the
theory that's out there is that at the
beginning of infinity war the hulk that
loki surprises Thanos with when he says
we have a hulk is actually Loki in this
ize something that we've seen the god of
mischief do before meanwhile the loci
that Thanos choked to death could have
been a projection of himself something
we've also seen Loki do before when
Heimdall uses a by for us to transport
hulk slash banner to earth now theory
suggests that he actually did that to
Loki disguise his banner and that Loki
would know where the sanctum sanctorum
is since he already met Doctor Strange
there in Ragnarok and it's actually Loki
warning Tony and the others about Thanos
not banner
maybe Loki would have assumed banner
would be the most trusted figure to
unite the Avengers since you know the
rest of them still hate Loki's guts and
throughout the rest of the movie Loki is
unable to convincingly portray Hulk but
he proves to be a pretty badass version
of banner in the battlefield like
despite a broken home Buster he was able
to defeat Coll obsidian remember banner
also got super excited when Thor showed
up in the battle outside Wakanda which
could have just been the god of mischief
expressing relief that his brother's
alive meanwhile this theory suggests
that the real Hulk Bruce Banner is
safely with behalf of the Asgardians
that Thanos didn't kill including
Valkyrie and Korg and meek now sure this
is all super interesting but I think
there is a reason that Thanos as he
killed Loki said no resurrections this
time if the filmmakers had some secret
agenda to later reveal Loki is not
actually dead again they would not have
included this line infinity war featured
lots of character deaths some seemed a
little cryptic well others were given
their own heavy emotional moments the
deaths of Loki and Gomorrah were about
as certain and final as one can get in a
pg-13 movie they both carried dramatic
consequences for the events that
followed in any future attempt to
reverse those deaths or retroactively
Lee revealed them as mr. X would kind of
feel like cheating and I think the
creatives at Marvel are better
storytellers than that I think Finn yes
it is odd that banner retained hoaxes
memories I suppose it's possible that
Hulk had reverted back to banner after
Ragnarok and then banner overheard
damaged his plan and then maybe he
turned back in a hog off screen right
before Loki said we have a Hulk at the
end of the day when I think about the
interpretation I found the most
satisfying as a viewer and the one I
expect the filmmakers intended Bruce
Banner ironically unable to get it up
when he needs Hulk the most is a really
fun character development that I don't
find that confusing until
the internet made me think too hard
about everything thanks Internet
well had a question for you guys do you
think Hulk would have been effective
against Thanos in that final battle
one-on-one earlier on he was overwhelmed
but I think one Hulk smash after Thor
hit Thanos what that Stormbreaker could
have been helpful also do you think it's
possible that banners Hulk identity
could have been among the heroes who
faded away and Thanos is snap hmm
comment down below with your thoughts or
tweet me directly at a vas and follow
new rock stars on Twitter for updates on
our videos like this video share it
around subscribing to rock stars for all
of our Avengers and Marvel theories and
if you thought the theory about Loki
being in disguise was too bogus think
again